[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم معنا في نقاش فرانس 24
او على صفحه البرنامج على تويتر
نتحدث عن قيمه المناخ في شرم الشيخ تقارير
الامم المتحده تصف الوضع البيئي في العالم
بالفوضووي كوارث طبيعيه بارتفاع غير مسبوق
لدرجه الحراره وفيضانات وحرائق عامه
المعموره ما تسبب في خسائر ماليه بمليارات
الدولارات وفي خدم الازمات المتعدده التي
يعيشها العالم عندما الطاقه والغذاء
والديون الى جانب الحرب في اوكرانيا هل
يمكن لقمه شرم الشيخ ان تقدم حلولا للرافه
بالبيئه الى اي حد الدول الغنيه ستقبل
بتعويض الخسائر التي سجلتها دور الجنوب
بسبب الاحتباس الحراري سعيد بان نناقش
الموضوع معنا معي هنا في الاستديو زميلي
في موتكر الدخله حسنه ليلي متخصص في
التنميه المستدامه والسياسات البيئيه سعيد
بان تكون معي من تونس اسيا قصدي وهي منسقه
برنامج اصوات من اجل العمل المناخي من
سيكون معنا من شرم الشيخ بعد قليل ممدوح
سؤال وهو امين عامل اتحاد العربي للشباب
والبيئه اهلا وسهلا بكم بانتظار طبعا وصول
الضيف الثالث من شرم الشيخ نستمر ما قاله
الامين العام للامم المتحده تونيو غوتيرش
هذه القمه
نحن في معركه من اجل حياتنا ونحن نخسرها
انبعاثات غازات الاحتباس الحراري ما زالت
مرتفعه الاحتباس الحراري لا يزال يتزايده
كوكبنا قريب من نقطه حيث تصبح الفوضى
المناخيه غير قابله للتغيير نحن على
الطريق السريع المتجه نحو الجحيم المناخي
وماذا قال الرئيس الفرنسيه مليان ماكرون
فان معركه ناهيه مع الدول
منها
الاوروبيونهم الوحيدون الذين يدفعون ثمن
هذه الانبعاثات
لكي تدفع حصتها
يجب ان لا ننسى ان هذه المعركه من اجل
المناخ ضد التغيرات المناخيه هي معركه لا
يمكن فصلها عن المعركه من اجل الحفاظ على
التنوع البيئي وان هاتين المعركتين هما
توام
البيئي
ان الدول التي ينظر اليها غالبا على انها
الاكثر فقرا هي الحل للكفاح ضد التغير
المناخي
وماذا قال الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي
انما يحتاجه عالمنا اليوم يتجاوز مجرد
الشعارات والكلمات
عندما تنتظره منا شعوبنا اليوم
هو التنفيذ السريع والفعال والعادل
تتوقع منا شعوبنا خطوات حقيقيه
الممثل الخاص لرئيس مؤتمر المناخ
حقيقه الامر ان ازمه المناخ هي ازمه
وجوديه للبشريه جمعاء ولا تحتمل تاخيرا
وقد شهد هذا العام على وجه التحديد صدور
عده تقارير علميه من الاي بي سي سي ومنظمه
الامم المتحده للبيئه تؤكد ان امامنا
فجاوات عديده في ما يخص التخفيف وفيما يخص
التكيف وفيما يخص التمويل وبالتالي لا
خيار امام البشريه الا العمل باقصى سرعه
لسد هذه الفجوات بصرف النظر عن وجود عوامل
مساعده في حين او عوامل معيقه في احيان
اخرى حتى هذه القمه مفيده يمكن ان
ننتقل معها من الاقوال الى الافعال
الواقع اولا مرحبا بمشاهدي قناه
التي اراها الان على الشاشه اييي القمم
المناخ بشكل عام
تتقدم بشكل بطيء جدا يعني بعض منظمات
المجتمع المدني استخدمت
استمدت صوره من سباق الخيل قالت
التغير المناخي يركض
والاسره الدوليه تمشي خببا يعني الجواد
الذي يمشي سببا يفترض ان يتهيا لان يركض
بعد ان يمشي خببا ولكن ما يلاحظ في قمم
المناخ منذ عام قال يعني منذ بدايه القرن
الى الان ان المشي خببا ظل ماشيا خببا حتى
الان وبالتالي هناك تساؤلات عن هذا الجواد
الذي يركض وراء التغير المناخي هل هو جواد
بحق ام انه حيوان اخر او شخص اخر
جواد العربي الاصيل فيه شويه
نعم وبالتالي يعني بشكل عام
القمم المناخ لحد الان ومؤتمرات كوب لان
القمم تبدا ثم تليها فيما بعد مفاوضات في
اطار المؤتمر بشكل عام ادت الى بعض
النتائج لو لهذه القمم لكانت درجات
الحراره قد ارتفعت اكثر مما ارتفعت عليه
الان وبالتالي ناقوس الخطر يدق من قبل
الذين يشاركون في هذه القمم ولا سيامو
منظمات المجتمعات ومع ذلك عندما ينظر الى
حصاد هذه القمم نراه وهزيلا جدا يعني
يشبه حاله هذا الجواد الذي يمشي
ههه جواد يمشي خببا تعطيانها مسعد معنا من
شرم الشيخ يعني هل هناك نفس من التفاؤل
بهذه القمه هذه المره وانت التي تتابعين
الاعمال منذ هذا الصباح
المدني كذلك عديد المفوضين من من عده دول
عربيه همم يجب ان يتفائل الجميع همم فكما
تعلم توفيق دخلنا في مرحله الطوارئ
المناخيه همم القمه الرئاسه المصريه للقمه
تتحدث عن قمه التنفيذ يجب ان همم يعني
تتجسد الوعود التي نسمعها منذ عام 2009
بافعال كما تعلم همم هذه السنه ربما من
اسخن سنوات يعني تم تسجيلها همم وتيره
التغير المناخ تتسارع اثار تغير مناخ باتت
واضحه في كل بقاع الارض من فيضانات
باكستان ونيجيريا الى
الجفاف في القرن الافريقي الى حرائق
الغابات التي اشى على ضفافه المتوسط
الاعاصير التي ضربت الساحله الشرقي
للولايات المتحده يعني وحتى موجات الحر في
اوروبا فبالتالي اليوم همم نعلم ان
الاحترار وتره الاحترار تتسارع همم هدف
اتفاق باريس وان لا يتخطى الاحترار الدرجه
فاصل خمسه الا انه بلغ حتى الان قراب
الدرجه فاصله اثنين بالتالي اليوم هناك
ضغوط كبيره على المفوضين اوكي همم بدايه
همم يرفع ربما سقف التعهدات التي قدمتها
بلدانهم للحد من انبعاثاتها من الغازات
الذريه
التمويل اليوم دول الجنوب موجوده هنا
بكثافه وتطالب الدول الصناعيه المسؤوله
التاريخيه
بالتالي هي مضطره للتفاؤل او على اي حال
للعمل في سبيل الوصول او التوصل الى حل
اسيا غزه انت بالتاكيد تتابعينا هذه القمه
لكي نظره نقديه لبيجري في هذه
القمم يعني ما هي هذه اسباب التردد طبعا
حسان هنا وصف الامور
بالجواد الذي لا يركض ولكن متى سيرقض هذا
الجواد
قاسي قاسي قاسي اساسي
الان نحن في القمه عدد 27 يعني منذ سنه
1995 تاريخ انطلاق اول قمه في مدينه برلين
الى حد الان وضعنا هدف همم
وهو همم
تحديد همم او همم ايقاف همم زياده
الانبعاثات الغازات الدافئه همم على
الكوكب ولكن منذ ذلك التاريخ والى اليوم
ونحن تقريبا نناقش نفس المواضيع همم نمشي
على نفس المسار بنفس السرعه تقريبا مع بعض
لنقل بعض التقدم الذي احرز من من من مؤتمر
لمؤتمر خاصه في اتفاق باريس خاصه في نتائج
كود 26 في كلاسكو كان ااا اذا اذا نقوم ب-
اا تقييم ل همم المسار لهذا المسار الذي
دام على مده 27 سنه فنحن لازلنا تقريبا لن
نباح ما كاننا همم بل بالعكس همم اثبتت
همم
السياقات السياسيه الحاليه ان الدول اا
وخاصه الدول المتسببه بالفعل في الاحتباس
الحراري والدول الاكثر همم
الاكثر تسببا في ذلك همم اثبتت ان المصالح
الاقتصاديه والمصالح السياسيه همم على
مصالح الكوكب وتدخل خاصه على صالح دول
الجنوب الاكثر تضررا من اثار التغيرات
المناخيه والتي تعتبر هشاشه والاكثر عرضه
لهذه الاثار
وكاننا وكان هذه الدول عندما همم نقوم
بالحديث او عندما نتحدث او عندما يتعلق
الامر همم بالتمويلات هناك همم تراجع هناك
همم مماطله همم هناك خاصه المماطله في وضع
اليات همم
لتمويل المناخ وحتى تمويل المتوفر او وعود
التمويل هي وعود من اجل التخفيف لدول
تساهم بنسبه ضعيفه جدا في هذه الانبعاثات
اذا تحدثنا عن القاره الافريقيه فهي تساهم
في بثلاثه في المئه فقط من انبعاثات
الغازات المتسببه الاحتباس الحراري ولكن
الاضرار والخسائر
والتاثير التغير المناخي هو تاثير كبير
جدا لا يقارن بنسبه الانبعاثات التي
تسببها دولتنا لذلك همم نحن نرى او كاننا
بدانا نوعا ما نفقد الامل في هذه
المفاوضات التي همم تماطل وتطول من دون
همم نتائج همم ملموسه لنقل ذلك
الان المطالبه على الطاوله هو ضروره تقديم
تعويضات كل الدول التي تاثرت بسبب
الاحتباس الحراري هل هذا الطلب قابل
للتنفيذ خاصه في ظل الظروف التي يعيشها
العالم والازمات بسبب حرب اوكرانيا حاليا
وحرب الطاقه والديون وماذا ذلك اولا ربما
اقول ربما ضاره نافعه هذه الازمه ازمه
الطاقه اليوم وارتفاع اسعار الطاقه دفعت
بالبلدان الاوروبيه والبلدان الغربيه الى
البدء في ترشيد استخدام الطاقه وكثير من
المدن هنا في فرنسا وكثير اكتشفت انها
كانت تهضر الطاقه همم هذا همم مهم هذه
النقطه ولكن بشكل عام مساله
الخسائر التي تطال هذه البلدان منذ بدايه
الثوره الصناعيه لا ننسى ان هذه العمليه
استمرت يعني من من منتصف القرن التاسع عشر
الى الان وبالتالي ط بلدان كثيره حتى قبل
ان تستقل وبلدان كانت تحت الاستعمار ومع
ذلك
طرحت القضيه من قبل منظمات المجتمع المدني
ومن قبل البلدان الناميه منذ 40 عاما
تقريبا وتطرح اول مره يبدا فيها الاستماع
الى حد شبه استماع الى هذا المطلب هي قمه
كلاسكو اول مره بشكل رسمي
في اول يوم هو في قمه شرم الشيخ وطبعا
المبالغ الماليه التي تطالب بها البلدان
الناميه
لتعويض عن الاضرار والخسائر التي طالتها
هي قدرت من قبل الخبراء بين 270 الى 580
مليار دولار كل عام حتى عام 2030 ومن عام
2030 الى عام
2050,700 مليار دولار في السنه وهي
مبالغمه يعني تحدثتم عن باكستان وتحدث
الزميله تقطيع قبل وقدمت صوره عن الخارطه
اليوميه اليوم
لاحتداد الكوارث الطبيعيه وما يسمى
الظواهر المناخيه القصوى
وما حصل في باكستان اكبر من ثلث المباراه
والمياه وال 30 الى 50 مليار هي كلفه
الاضرار الاقتصاديه هذه المساله طرحت الان
وضعت على الاجنده يعني ما الحقيقه من خلال
تجربه الشخصيه مع هذه القمم ومن خلال ما
استمع اليه من قبل الخبراء ستضمن كما لو
كانت نقطه ايجابيه في هذا المؤتمر ولكن
شتان بين تضمين هذه هذا المطلب وبين
التفعيل حتى عنوان هذا المؤتمر يعني معا
نحوه التنفيذ كلمه نحو او عباره نحوه يعني
متوسط واوفق بعيد ثابت بطبيعه الحال كل
هذه التزامات التي تلتزم بها البلدان
الصناعيه حتى البلدان الناميه هي على
متوسط وبعيد وليس ثمه اليه تضبط هذه
الالتزامات وتعاقب الناس الذين يخلون
بالتزاماتهم بسبب بسيط هو ان الاتفاق
باريس اراد ان يدرج الاسره الدوليه كلها
في المساله واراد ان تكون هذه الالتزامات
توعيه ولكن ان ياتي الشخص ثم يقول انا هذه
التزامات
ويكتب ارقام ويكتب حروف دون ان يفعل هذه
الالتزامات بشكل عملي على الاقل على
المستوى الان وعلى المستوى ال- ال-
المتوسط فهذه مشكله في المنهجيه التعامل
مع اليه اتفاق باريس بما ان حسان تحدث على
التزامات وسمعنا من الماكرونه يقول ان
الحرب في اوكرانيا لا يجب ان تنسيمات ولا
يمكن ان نضحي بهذه الالتزامات بسبب الحرب
في اوكرانيا يعني عندما الناس مع الناس
تقارير الامميه اننا التقرير نرى
الانذارات ونسمع الكلام وكان الفجوه كبيره
خاصه التقا
رير الكميه الدوليه المعنيه بتغيير المناخ
التي سترت منذ العام الماضي يعني منذ قمه
جلاسكو تشير الى ان
الاحترار يتساراع
والسيناريوهات اسوا بكثير مما كان متوقعا
في البدايه وكما قلت سابقا لاحظنا ذلك همم
يعني هناك اجماع من العلماء حول هذا
الموضوع ولكن في الوقت نفسه على ارض
الواقع يعني منذ اندلاع الحرب في روسيا
وهمم وتخلي الاوروبيين تدريجيا عن الغاز
الروسيه قام الاوروبيون بالاستثمار في
مصادر جديده للوقود الاحفوري وفي الفحم
همم وقعدوا اذا انفتح محطات لانتاج الطاقه
بالفحم وهي من ربما من اكثر المواد
الملوثه او المسببه الانبعاثات الغازات
الدفيئه همم هذا ربما يفسر ما قاله همم
ولكن على ارض الواقع حتى ان الدول
الاوروبيه اليوم تبحث عن مصادر جديده
للوقود الاحفوري في الدول الافريقيه لذلك
في خلال الاعداد لقمه لقمه شرم الشيخ
اعلنت الدول الافريقيه انها لا تريد
التخلي الان عن الوقود الاحفوري وانه تريد
تحقيق التنميه عبر الاستثمار في الطاقه
الاحفوريه هذا هذا من جهه من من جهه اخرى
يعني بالحديث عن
المقاله هناك مساله مساله مهمه جدا همم
خاصه بالخسائر والاضرار تحدث اكيد عن
مساله التمويل المئه مليار دولار همم التي
وعدت بها الدول الصناعيه عام 2009 في قمه
كوبنهاجن همم 100 مليار دولار سنويا على
الاقل ابتداء من عام 2020 قال بانه يجب
اخيرا ان يؤمن هذا المبلغ ولكنه لم يتحدث
فعلا عن الخسائر والاضرار همم اليوم فرنسا
ترفض ليس فقط فرنسا كل الدول الاوروبيه
والصناعيه عامه او الدول المسؤوله تاريخا
عن ظاهره الاحتباس الاحتباس الحراري ترفض
خلق صندوق اخر او فتح هذا الباب فتح باب
التعويضات على الدول التي عانت من كوارث
طبيعيه جراء تغير المناخ مع انها تعترف
اكيد بمسؤولياتها التاريخيه في همم في
تغير المناخ لان اكيد هذا المبلغ هذا
الباب فتح سيكلفها مليارات الدولارات
سنويا
يعني عندما نسمع كل هذا الكلام وكان
الكلام عن البيئه
وحمايه البيئه هي مجرد شعارات حتى الان
عندما يتعلق الامر بما صالح اقتصاديه ضيقه
لبعض الدول واكبر دليل على ذلك مثلا هو
غياب الصين في هذه القمه
اسف بالفعل عندما تتعلق يتعلق بالفعل
عندما يتعلق الامر
بالمصالح الاقتصاديه تنتفي المصالح
البيئيه او او ينتهي جانب حقوق الشعوب في
بيئه سليمه وحقوق الشعوب في العيش فقط
كانت تقريبا حرب اوكرانيا كانت هي بمثابه
الاختبار للدول الاوروبيه في علاقه همم
الالتزامات همم خفض انبعاثات الغازات
الدافئه لان كما اشارت همم مراسلات يكون
في شرم الشيخ فان هذه الدول قد ايه بالفعل
قد بدات في البحث عن مصادر طاقه همم
احفوريه جديده في دول افريقيا ومره اخرى
تتحمل دول افريقيا همم اضرار همم البحث عن
الطاقات الاحفوريه همم كذلك همم تتحمل
ايضا حتى اضرار الانتقال الطاقه واضرار
الاتجاه الى الطاقات المتجدده لان
الاستخراج يكون عاده في همم في دول
افريقيا اين توجد المصادر اين توجد
الموارد الطبيعيه همم فقط في مساله المناخ
قد ضلت هذه الدول تعطي شعارات ودروس حول
التخفيف دروس حول كيفيه العمل المناخي
وكيفيه مواجهه هذه الازمه ولكن عندما
ناتي الى تطبيق هذه الوعود عندما ناتي الى
مساله جبر الضرر همم مساله العهده على
الملوث وهو مبدا عالمي همم يحمل الملوث
مسؤوليه تلويفه للكوكب ومسؤوليه او همم
الاخطار المجره عن هذه عن هذا التلوث فهنا
يكون طبعا العامل الاقتصادي همم يسيطر
والعامل الاقتصادي هو من يحدد بالفعل هل
كانت هذه الدول المنتظمه همم بتعهداتها
وبشعاراتها التي لا طالما همم اا ولا
طالما جاءت بها منذ منذ اول قمه تقريبا
المناخ وكذلك يمكن حتى الحديث عن بقيه همم
بقيه الاتفاقيه التي تعنى بالبيئه مثلا
اتفاقيه مقاومه التصحر والتي تهم بالاساس
دول الجنوب لا تاخذ مثل الحيز الاعلامي
والحيز السياسي همم مثل التي تاخذه قمه
المناخ فقد لن نسمع بها تقريبا يمكن همم
هي تصير يعني تعقد مره كل ثلاث سنوات ولكن
الاهتمام بهذه القمه والتي تهم دول الجنوب
وتهم التصحر في دول الجنوب لا تلقى نفس
الزخم الذي همم تلقاه همم قمه المناخ لان
التغيرات المناخيه او هذه الاخطار هي تشمل
كيف الدول العالم همم بالتاكيد تشمل كيف
الدول العالم بنفسك كيفيه ااه وليس لنا
يعني نفس القدره على تحمل هذه الاضرار
ولكن فقط للاشاره انه ااا لما يتعلق الامر
بمصلحه دول الشمال فلا يمكن ان ااه فلا
يمكن الحديث
ولا يمكن الحديث عن طيب نعم وجدته فقدت
نحن اعتقد متفقون يعني اسيا وتتيانو انا
متفقون على هذه المسؤوليه الكبرى الملقاط
على عاتق البلدان المتقدمه ولكن لا ننسى
ايضا في الوقت الراهن مسؤوليه البلدان
الناميه في كيف تبدو هذه المسؤوليه نحن
نعرف ان العمل من اجل التنميه المستدامه
يتطلب عده اطراف اهم هذه الاطراف الدول
والايرادات السياسيه القويه ثم اشراك
منظمات المجتمع المدني ثم اشراك المنتجين
الدوله تشرع قوانين من يلوث من يرسل
الانبعاثات هم المنتجون هم الصناعيون وهم
المستهلكون في البلدان العربيه لحد الان
جمع او منظمات الاهليه التي تعنى
بالاستهلاك تهتم اساسا بالاسعار ولا تهتم
او لا تشجع على الاهتمام بتغيير سلوكيات
الاستهلاك نحن نسرف او بالبلدان العربيه
تسرف في اهدار الطعام وفي اهضار الماء وفي
اهدار الطاقه وانت ذكرت مثلا الخبز اعطيه
كمثلين اثنين في في في تونس وفي الاردن
الخبز يورما ويقدم اعلاف للحيوانات التي
تربى بشكل المكثف لان سعر الخبز الذي يرمى
به في سله المهملات وفي سله النفايات او
يعطى لهذه الابقار اقل بكثير من سعر
الاعلاف لانهم يدعوه من قبل الدوله
وبالتالي البلدان النامي عليها ان تراجع
راس على عقب منظومه الدعم المنتجات لان
ال- ال- ال- الثري يشتري الخبزه بنفس
السعر الذي لا فلسفه ثم يهدر هذا الخبز
يعني هناك بالامكان تقديم الا الدعم الى
مستحقه والحقيقه الالامكانيه موجوده هذا
شيء الشيء الثاني بالنسبه الى المنظومه
العلميه او الطرف العلمي اليوم وانا اكرر
دائما انطلاقا من تجربتك اعلامي متخصص في
هذا الجانب المعلومه العلميه اصبحت اساسيه
في العمل التنموي الذي ياخذ بعين الاعتبار
الاعتبارات الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
والبيئيه وبالتالي البحث العلمي في
البلدان الناميه
وخاصه في البلدان العربيه يعني الموازنه
المخصصه للفتاه وياتي عاده من بلدان
خارجيه مثل الاتحاد الاوروبي وكثير من
اساتذه الجامعات العربيه والمختبرات
والابحالات همم زملائهم في الاتحاد
الاوروبي في في الجامعات الاردن هم الذين
يتدخلون حتى يشركوهم في بعض المشاريع وهذه
مسؤوليه السلطات في البلدان الناميه ليست
مسؤوليه البلدان الصناعيه او البلدان
المتقدمه التالي هذا الخطاب الذي فيه
العالم الثالث او العالمبي وهو بكاء شكاء
يعني وصل الى حده العالم النام لديه قدرات
هائله من الكفاءات البشريه لا يستغلها كما
ينبغي هذه الكفاءات موجوده في البلدان
العربيه وخارج البلدان العربيه لا يستغلها
لانه لا ينظر الى البحث العلمي والى
المعلومه العلميه كما ينبغي ان ينظر اليها
وهي السلاح اساس لان الانتصار على التغير
المناخي يمر عبر المعرفه وبالتالي همم هذه
نواقص او عوائق موجوده عند العالم الثالث
وعند البلدان الناميه ولا بد من الاقرار
بها ايضا هذه بعض الامثله طبعا طيب انا
لست ادري كان ضعيف ولو انها امين
لا عفوا اتفضل اتفضل اتفضل يا ياسر
كنا نتحدث عن المسؤوليه التاريخيه للدول
الملوثه في ازمه المناخ
وايضا في عديد الازمات الاخرى المتعلقه
بالتلوث بنقل الصناعات الملوثه لبلدان فقط
اشاطر الراي في مساله الاستهلاك ولكن همم
ما فائدتنا او ما هي النتيجه التي سنحصل
عليها اذا خفضنا في انبعاثتنا الى الطاقات
المتجدده او اذا رشدنا استهلاكنا بالفعل
نحن في حاجه الى ترشيد استهلاك لان
مواردنا محدوده همم لاننا اذا لم نستهلك
هذه الموارد بصفه مستدامه ولم نستغل لها
بصفه مستدامه فالخاصر هو نحن بالاكيد ولكن
ان يحمل نفسنا مسؤوليه التغير المناخي
ومسؤوليه هذه الانبعاثات فهو همم بمسابه
الحي على دوالينا ولكن كما اشرت همم
الاستهلاك المستدام للموارد الطبيعيه ان
ان كذلك التوعيه الذي والتي هي دور مهم من
من الادوار التي يطلع بها ويقوم بها تقوم
بها منظمه المجتمع المدني هذا لا نختلف
فيه ولكن ايضا حتى مساله مساله يعني البحث
العلمي هناك العديد من الطاقات التي
موجوده في البلدان العربيه موجوده في
الاردن في تونس في المغرب في مصر في
العديد من الدول وهي تشتغل وتناظر من اجل
قضيه المناخ ومن اجل القضايا البيئيه ايضا
هناك العديد حتى من الجامعات الموجوده في
تونس والتي تدرس وهي مختص في القضايا
البيئيه همم فهذا همم
نحن نتحدث عن اضرار وخسائر تتجاوز قدرتنا
على التحمل وكل من اخطا اكيد عبر التاريخ
عليها ان يتحمل المسؤوليته عليها ان يضع
المال الذي ربحه في السابق من اجل جبره
هذه الاضرار ومن اجل تعويذه الخسائر
لبلدان لطالمانت ال- اا من التلوث ولكن
لما قررت يده البلدان ان همم تسير في نهج
التنميه فقد وجدنا همم طبعا همم مساله
التغير المناخي والتي تعوقنا ف- فهذه
الفقضيه التغير المناخي هي قضيه معقده جدا
همم ترتبط حتى بسياقه المحليه التي نحن
موجودين فيها فقط نقطه اخيره وهي في علاقه
بالمعارف والحلول التي يمكن ان يعتمدها
همم
الحلول التي يمكن ان يعتمدها حتى تعتمدها
المجتمع المجتمعات المحليه في التاقلم وفي
الصمود امام هذه الاثار
باختصار انا قلت اننا متفقون على
المسؤوليه البلدان المتقدمه في التلويث
وفي الانبعاثات ومع ذلك المنهجيه السليمه
تقتضي ان يتم ان نكون واقعيين ان نطالب
وان لا نظل نبكي ونولي يعني لدينا امكانات
في العالم
النامي ولكن الايرادات السياسيه ليست
متوفره بما فيه الكفايه سلوكيات الانتاج
والاستهلاك يعني المستهلك لديه دور كبير
جدا في تغيير في التاثير على صاحب القرار
السياسي وصاحب القرار ال- ال- الاقتصادي
ولكن لماذا لا يخرج الشباب في العالم
العربي بالملايين مثل ما يحصل في بلدان
اخرى لان القضيه لحد الان لم تصل الى حد
اقران ايضا الفعل بالقول الناس واعون
بالمشاكل ولكنهم لا يتحركون بما فيه كفايه
يعني قال همم لا يتحركون باعتبار ان هذا
الكوكب هو قريه صغيره لكل الناس وانه على
كل شخص وعلى كل بلديه وعلى كل منطقه او
محافظه وعلى ان تعمل وتطالب الاخرين
بالعمل يعني ان نسكت وان نقول اذا لم نعمل
الاخر فنحن لم نعمل ليست المنهجيه السليمه
هذا موادته تاكيد عليه
الان ممدوح راشوان امين عام الاتحاد
العربي للشباب والبيئه كنا نتمنى تكون
معنا منذ البدايه تتطرقنا للعديد من
الرياضيه وصلنا الى عمل المجتمع المدني هل
المجتمع المدني يتحرك بما فيه الكفايه في
المغرب في في مصر في مجال البيئي وهل له
الحريه التامه في ذلك لانه هناك حتى
انتقادات بان هذه الحريه مقيده في مصر حتى
في مجال به
مساء الخير وانا بعتذر بس اللي كان في
جلسه مهمه كنت بحضرها فعشان كده اولا
المجتمع المصري المدني بخير احنا اكثر من
60 الف منظمه مصريه
مشارك عدد كبير مننا في هذا اللقاء ولينا
جناح كبير جدا ولينا فعاليات شغاله على
مدار على مدار ال ال ال الفعاليات كلها
فالحمد لله المجتمع بتاعنا بخير وله رؤيا
ومشارك في سن القرار وبدليل ان حتى
استراتيجيه تتغير المناخ المصري عملتها 20
30 20 50 كان مشارك فيها المجتمع المدني
بشكل اساسي وكان له دور في وضع سياسي مصر
تجاه قضيه تغير المناخي ومعالجه تغير
المناخي وايتاحه جزء في هذا المؤتمر
للمنظمات المجتمع المدني المصري همم
واجداح كبير في المنطقه الزرقاء يعرض
نشاطه ويعرض تجاربه ده اكبر دليل على
مشاركه المجتمع المدني المصري يعني طيب
الان هناك مطالبه للدول الغنيه بان ت على
الاقل او من اجل المشاركه في جبر الاضرار
التي نجمت عن الاحتباس الحراري هناك امل
بالتجاوب مع هذا المطلب
طبعا طبعا النهار ده زعماء العالم كلهم
موجودين ويمكن احنا يعني مورينا بتجربه
كبيره من اول 2004 لغايه ما اخذنا
الاتفاقيه في 2015 في باريس يعني من 2004
الاتفاقيه كانت موجوده ولم يتم التوقيع
عليها غير في 2015
وبتادت يعني اتفاقيه الاتاريه ابتدت تخش
حيث التنفيذ والتعهد بالمئه مليار همم
دولار اللي ابتعد فعلا يتجمع وده عشان
يثبت المصداقيه ال- ال- الدول قدام ال-
ال- الدول الاخرى قدام العالم كله ف- همم
انا شايف النهارده تجاوب زعماء العالم لان
الكوب ده بيوصل للي بعديه واللي قابليه هي
زي السباق تتبع بتستلم الرايه من اللي
قبليك وتتكمل يعني هو مش انا الكوب في
الوصول الاتفاقيات يعني ان هم الدول
تتوافق على الاتفاقيات فاحنا مشكلتنا بس
في حاجه واحده وكانت من الدول الصناعيه
اللي هي ال- ال- الحد من ال- من التعامل
مع مع
خذ العفوري او التخلص التدريجي يعني هم
قالوا اخر حاجه كان في باريس ان هم يقللوا
من استخدامه احنا عايزين نوصل للتخلص
التدريجي منه ان شاء الله حتى لو بعد 50
سنه وده هيقضي او حتى على الاقل نشتغل 50%
وقود احفوري و50% طاقه متجدده يعني ده
ابسط حل يعني اللي لقيته المنظمات واللي
العالم كله يعني شبه ابتدا يتوافق به لان
احنا كلنا في مركب واحد وكلنا ابتدينا نحس
يعني النهارده الفيلم اللي اتعرض قدام
رؤساء العالم كله بيبين الكوارث اللي جايه
من من التغيرات كوارث فعليه حصلت السنه دي
يعني كانت الرساله لهم عاوزين يعني كل
العالم كله شافها وكل الرؤساء شافوا
بنفسهم ايه الكوارث اللي ممكن تحدث وتقضي
على شعوبهم يعني وعلى العالم كله يعني كيف
يمكن ان نقتنع بان التوصيات التي
ستنجم عن قمه شرم الشيخ ستكون مختلفه عن
توصيات القيمه الاخرى
والله احنا بنحاول في هذه القمه انها تكون
قمه تنفيذ يعني وليس اقوال زي ما يعني
اطلاقه
احنا عاملين يعني جلسات اللي نشوف ايه
اللي تم في ال في القمه السابقه ومن اليات
وبرامج وتم تنفيذها وايه اللي ما يتوقف
منها يعني بنراجع مع نفسنا وبنراجع مع
الدول وبالراجع مع الاتفاقيه بوجود
المنظمات كمراقب بتشوف ايه اللي تم وايه
التعرق في الجهود وايه اللي احنا هنكمله
فده ان شاء الله في في القمه دي متوقع
وطبعا بضغط من من الرؤساء لان الرؤساء
ابتدوا يقتنعوا بقضيه التغيرات المناخيه
يمكن كانت ضمن القضايا يعني ترتيبها كان
يعني مش في الاهميه عندهم لكن اعتقد
بحضورهم والحضور الكم الكبير من الرؤساء
ده ده بيدل على اهتمامه دي ظهرت في القمم
او في ال- همم في ال همم كذا اجتماع اطراف
الاخيره يعني حوالي ثلاث اربع سنين سابقه
لكن قبل كده ما كانش بيحصل فيه زخم من
رؤساء والملوك وقاده العالم ان هم يحضروا
يعني كانوا بيسيبوا اللي فرق التفاوض
بتاعه بلدهم فاعتقد ان ده اهتمام بيهم لان
هم شافوا ولمسوا بنفسهم ايه الكوارث اللي
بتحدث في العالم وهما بيتاثروا بها
وشعوبهم بيتاثروا بها يعني وكان الامور
موسمين
الواقعه مثل ما ذكرت في البدايه القمم لا
تحل كل المشاكل ولكنها تساعد على التقدم
خطوه بخطوه واريد ان يوضح ان البلد البلد
المضيف اذا ناجح في تنظيم القمه وعمل على
تقريب وجهات النظاره فيعتبر نجاح للبلد
لان المساله مطروح برمتها على الاسره
الدوليه كلها يعني ما تشكو منهم منظمات
المجتمع المدني منذ زمان انها تشرك في
المفا- لا تشرك في المفاوضات بما فيه
الكفايه صحيح في السنوات الاخيره اصبح
الحيز المفتوح امامها افضل مما كان عليه
الامر من قبل ولكن المنظمات المجتمع
المدني بدات الان ان ال رفع الشعارات لا
يكفي ثم انه عمل المشترك يعني نحن نعرف ان
المنظمات التي تقول نحن سنقوم نحن سنقوم
يعني هو عمل مشترك بين السلطات المحليه
وبين المواطن وبين الصناعيين والمنتجين
والاوساط العلميه والتعاون
الدوليين لان الشعارات في الحقيقه ترفع من
قبل البلدان الشماليه والجنوبيه هذه
القيمه التي حضرتها يعني هناك همم بشكل
روتيني ياتي المسؤول الاول رئيس الوزراء
او رئيس الدوله
ويقول الخارطه سوداء
العالم مقبل على الهاويه ثم يقول نحن
عملنا ونحن قمنا ونحن قمنا وفي النهايه
اذا كان من البلدان الناميه ساعدونا بالله
عليكم ساعدونا بالنسبه للبلدان الشماليه
وما قاله السيد مكروه يقول نحن بخير
في اوروبا ونحن لسنا مقصرين تجاه البلدان
الناميه لابوها همم الولايات المتحده
والصين مقسرتان لا التقصير هو عام وتقصير
البلدان الصناعيه التي تملك التكنولوجيا
وتملك المعلومه العلميه وتتحكم في
المعلومه العلميه وتنتج المعلومه العلميه
صحيح انه ان واجبها اكبر من واجبات
البلدان الناميه ولكن للبلدان الناميه
واجبات افرادا وجماعات
وكل الاطراف معنيه بالموضوع هسه تريدين
التفاعل مع ضيفه في شرم الشيخ تفضل
نعم نعم نعم
اكيد اتفاعل مع الضيفين من همم تحياتي
لضيف من شرم الشيخ الدكتور رشوان وتحياتي
ابدا همم ضيفك في الاستوديو همم فقط اريد
الاشاره انه همم مثلا بعض الدول الاوروبيه
همم تتحدث عن الامن المناخي بدات بالفعل
تؤمن حدودها ضد المهاجرين بطريقه كبيره
همم ايضا تؤمن البنيه التحتيه طبعا من اجل
مجابهته ومواجهه اثار التغيرات المناخيه
فهناك نوعا ما من همم لنقل همم التعامل
بطريقه غير متوازنه مع هذه القضيه
بالاضافه الى انه مثلا همم بالنسبه لاتفاق
باريس همم ينص على ان الدول عليها ان تقدم
او ترفع طموحاتها وترفع التزاماتها كل خمس
سنوات فقد تقريبا 23 او 24 دوله بعد همم
بعد قمه كلاسكو كوب 26 قدم او رفعت من
طموحاتها بما فيهم بما فيهم تونس رفعت
طموحاتها في التخفيف من الام في
الانبعاثات في الانبعاثات الغازات من نسبه
41% الى نسبه 45% همم فهذا همم لا يدل الا
على ان الدول ليست ملتزمه بالطريقه
الكافيه او بالكيفيه همم او على قدر
التحدي المناخي الذي نواجهه نحن مطالبون
بتخفيض 43% همم من انبعاثتنا الى حدود
2030 اليوم هناك ارتفاع
بعشره.6% اا يعني هذا يدل على ان حتى
الالتزامات هي لازاله التزامات على الورق
همم ليست الجن التزامات مطابقه وحتى
بالرجوع الى اتفاق باريس في حد ذاته فهو
فهي التزميات غير ملزمه للدول وليس هناك
من يحاسبها اذا هي قامت بالفعل بتطبيق
التزاماتها او همم منظمات المجتمع لولا
ضغطتها الذي مارسته لطيله سنوات في مختلف
همم مؤتمرات الاطراف في مختلف المنصات
التي اتيحت لها همم
لا يمكننا الوصول الا النتيجه التي وصلنا
اليها اليوم لا يمكن الوصول الى وضع
الاضرار والخسائر او اليه تمويل الاضرار
والخسائر على طاوله مفاوضات لان اليه همم
الاضرار والخسائر كانت قد وضعت بالفعل همم
في همم كوب 19 بمدينه في بولونيا ولكن هذه
الاليه كانت اليه فقط لدعم الدول الاوليه
لدعم قدورات الدول الجنوب على مجابهه اثار
التغيرات المناخيه او مجابهه الظواهر
المناخيه المتطرفه ولكن لم توضع اليه
لتمويل هذه الاضرار والخسائر في هذه
النتائج التي وصلت اليها او النتائج
القليله التي توصلت اليها المجموعه
الدوليه هي نتيجه لضغط منظمه المجتمع
المدني وليست فقط شعارات مرفوعه بل هناك
عمل فعلي واعمال الميداني لمنظمات المجتمع
المدني على المستوى المحلي والوطني
والدولي والاقليم لا يمكن القول انه
منظمات المجتمع المدني ترفع شعارات فقط
اذا نتحدث بهذه الطريقه يعني ان الدول
لقد تقول كلاما ولا تطبخه همم هذا ما اردت
ان همم
اقولها حول دور منظمات المجتمع المدني
يعني رغم ان نحنا من منظمات مجتمع مدني
ومفروض ان احنا نبقى واقفين للحكومات
بالمرصاد لكن انا شايف الرؤيه ونجاح الكوب
اللي احنا فيه والسابق يعني ده دليل ان
احنا فعلا ابتدينا ناخد وخطوات جيده لانه
فعلا بقول لك ال- ال- الزعماء ابتدوا
يحسوا بالخطوره على شعوبهم وبالخطوره على
نفسهم من من خلال الازمات التغيرات
المناخيه اللي العالم كله المواطن البسيط
دلوقت رغم انها قضيه علميه بقى يفهمها وده
نجاح الكب ونجاح المؤتمرات الاعتراف يعني
عايز اقول لك ان في مصر دلوقت ال- ال-
الفلاح البسيط او المواطن بسيط بقى يعرف
عن قضيه التغيرات المناخيه وان ده ي- ي-
يرجعنا لاهميته وجود ال- ال- المؤتمر دوت
في مصر
ونجاح ونجحه قدر يوصل ان اهتمام كبير
لل120 عايز اقول لك مثلا ممكن يبقى 90
منهم 90 مليون اصبحوا يهتموا بقضيه
التغيرات المناخيه
في اولوياتهم والحاجات الب الجمعيات ليها
دور كبير انا كم منظمه مجتمع مدني انا
عندي بعد غدا عرض المشروع كبير كنت عامله
على مستوى المنطقه العربيه للشباب العالم
العربي عن عن التعامل الامن مع مخلفات
الالكترونيه وعلاقتها بالتغيرات المناخيه
فده معروض وده احد المشروعات العمليه يعني
احنا حتى منظمات انتقلنا من دور التوعيه
والوعي والتعريف لدور الممارسه العمليه
ومشاركه الحكومات لان احنا كلنا في كوكب
واحد وكلنا فرد واحده لو انتهت خلاص مش
هيبقى لنا مكان يعني او اندثر فعشان كده
لازم يبقى دورنا دورنا مكمل للحكومات
ودورنا منفذ وده الحمد لله الجمعيات
والمنظمات عرض شغل اعمامه عملي في هذا
اللقاء غير حملات التوعيه اللي كانت
بتعرضها سابقا يعني فده الحمد لله في هذا
اللقاء نجح نجح كبير وانا شفت النهارده
ردود الفعل على الفيلم اللي اتعرض يعني
اللي عرض كل المشاكل والكوارث اللي حصلت
السنه دي من التغيرات المناخيه وتشوف ال-
يعني على جوزاء يعني فده وايه يعني فعلا
يعني المؤتمر ابتدا يحقق ومتوقع من من كوب
شرم الشيخ ده يعني همم جهود فعلا هتبقى
مبزوله وجهود حثيثه
وننتقل للسنه الجايه لدبي يعني نكمل
الرايه ونكمل الفعاليات واعتقد يعني اينعم
برده مع الصوره الجميله ما رجعنا برده في
بعض الدول الاوروبيه والصناعيه للاسف
الشديد ابتدي ترجع ثاني تشتغل على الوقود
الاحفوري المانيا دلوقت ابتدات تشتغل
بالفحم ثاني يمكن لازمه الطاقه في العالم
ودي حروب ممكن تعمل هي حروب بعد كده
فاحنا بنوجهجه
بنلفت النظر لهذه الموضوع لان احنا
بنراقبهم عارفين ان ده يستخدم عقود وحوري
من جديد ده ابتدا همم يرجع ثاني لان نقط
اللي احنا كنا ابتدينا ننتهي منها يعني
يعني
على اهميه عمل منظمات المجتمع المدني
استقيمه من مصر ومن تونس في مصر
رايت منظمه اهليه منذ سنوات تعمل تعمل
خليه داخل الاسره وفيها وزارات يعني الاب
يهتم بالكهرباء الام تهتم بالماء البنت
تهتم ب وفعلا هذه التجربه كانت من من من
مبادره من منظمات المجتمع ونجحت الى حد
كبير في تقليص نفقات الاسره الى النصف
تقريبا حتى ان بعض الاسر تذهب في الصيف في
العطله ورشه استهلاك الطاقه والماء والخبز
واضرب مثل اخر من تونس ومنظمات المجتمع
المدني سمحت اليوم بالنسبه للصيادين
باستخدام ساعه في النخيل بدل البلاستيك
فعلا لسيد بعض الاسماك وهي مهمه جدا هذه
النتيجه ما وردت ان اقوله انه عمل جماعي
مشترك وان كل طرف عليه ان يتحمل مسئولياته
ويقوم بواجبه دون ان يقول انا بطل
وانا متفق مع همم
ضيف همم الضيف التونسيه ان ضمير العمل
البيئي التنموي هي منظمات المجتمع المدني
بطبيعه الحال هل الشكر في الختام لحسنه
لمتخصص في التنميه المستدامه والسياسيه
الشكر من تونس قصدي منسقط برنامج اصوات من
اجل العمل المناخيه والشكر من شرم الشيخ
لممدوح رشوان امين عام الاتحاد العربي
للشباب والبيئه والشكر لمفدت فرنسا
مريحه الجميع
[موسيقى]